deep in the jungles of Guatemala lie the
ruins of a lost Maya civilization the
culture thought of as the Classic Maya
flourished across Central America
between 250 and 900 AD but
archaeologists are now discovering a
Maya society that existed a full
thousand years before that in a time
they call the pre-classic many of its
remains lie buried at the lost city of
El Mirador archaeologist Richard Hanson
has worked for more than 20 years to
solve the Enigma of the early Maya
they're lost the history as of right now
we've never known who these individuals
were and never knowing what other than
seeing the physical evidence of their
prowess we've never had a chance to know
them personally and the work that we're
doing now is gonna be with a chance to
know these guys personally one of the
smaller pyramids of this lost city has
captured Richards imagination this is a
large war pod with an ear spool in the
middle that you see the ear spool here
and it has three realistic Jaguar claws
emanating from a from a realistic coot
achill here's another Jaguar claw here
and another one at the very bottom the
fact that we find this pre-classic
Jaguar paw coordinates very well with a
king we believe governed from 152 BC -
145 BC his name was um Chuck Chuck or
great fiery Jaguar paw and this may be a
symbol of this that's why this building
is so interesting to us because it's
possible that this King could be buried
here to test his theory Richard has
brought in the latest ground-penetrating
imaging system it's on this side it's on
this side yeah the liver meters down on
this side yeah and about a tangle of a
minute stuff yeah this is good news so
definitely there yeah
the system has revealed a cavity perhaps
eight by two meters just the right size
for a man
sniff isn't tomb this was construction
on an epic scale the results were all
inspiring a vast metropolis gleaming red
and white in the jungle Sun El Mirador
perhaps a hundred thousand people
hundreds of great buildings and at the
eastern end of the city the massive
pyramid of danta possibly the largest
pyramid ever built at El Mirador Richard
and his team have tunneled deep into the
Jaguar temple finally arriving at the
place where the imaging system showed a
cavity we broke through here we found
more fill in rubble there should have
been a chamber or something on the other
side of this of this wall this has the
setback there should have been something
there so the fact that it's not there
tells us that the elusive Khan Kings
are still Luis he is not going to give
up that easily at another temple he
prepares to excavate next season maybe
then he'll find the remains of an early
Maya king
[Music]